[Music]
the happy
prince a version of the tale by the
Fable cottage.com
high above the city stands the statue of
the happy
prince he is covered with fine gold leaf
his eyes are two blue
sapphires he has a big red ruby on his
sword everyone loves him
look at the happy prince says a mother
to her son who is crying his eyes out
the happy prince never cries don't you
want to be like
him well at least someone is happy in
this town mutters a grumpy man as he
contemplates the beautiful
statue he looks like an an angel say the
children in the
orphanage
[Music]
one night a little swallow flies over
the city he is all alone his friends all
flew away to Egypt 6 weeks
ago the swallow stayed behind because he
had fallen in love with the most
beautiful Reed she was tall and slender
and she moved so gracefully in the wind
the other swallows had laughed at this
romance oh it's so ridiculous they said
she has no money and no steady job then
Autumn arrived the other birds left for
Egypt and the little swallow began to
get tired of his lover well yes she is
beautiful but does she like to travel he
wondered of course my future wife must
like to
travel so he asked the Reed will you
come to Egypt with me it'll be so much
fun I'll show you the
pyramids but the Reed shook her head
very well I will go alone replied the
swallow
goodbye and he flew away towards the
city he arrives in the city after dark
now where am I going to sleep he wonders
he sees the statue of the happy prince
ah I will sleep there The View will be
Magnificent the swallow lands between
the feet of the happy prince he looks
around himself amazing I have a golden
bedroom he is just about to fall asleep
when plop a drop of water falls on his
head what is it raining
he wonders strange I don't see any
clouds then plop another Drop Falls on
him blousy statue he mutters it can't
even protect me from the rain maybe I
should find a nice chimney
instead but then plop another Drop Falls
the swallow looks up and what does he
see the ey eyes of the happy prince are
filled with
tears tears are streaming down his
golden cheeks his face looks so sad in
the Moonlight the little swallow is
filled with
pity who are you he asks the
statue I am the happy
prince well why are you crying then asks
the swallow I'm all
wet H you know when I was alive and had
a human heart I never cried the statue
says I lived in Sans suusi
Palace there is no sorrow at Sans
suusi every night I danced in the Great
Hall during the day I played with my
friends in the garden
there was a big wall around the garden
but I never asked what was on the other
side why would I ask everything around
me was so
beautiful when I was alive everyone
called me the happy prince and yes I was
happy if pleasure and happiness are the
same thing but then I died and they put
me here now I can see see all the
sadness and ugliness of my city my heart
is made of lead but I cannot stop
crying what he has a heart of lead I
thought he was solid gold thinks the
swallow to himself but he doesn't say it
out loud he's too
polite far from here continues the
statue far from here there is a small
Street
in this street there is a small
house one of the windows is open and I
can see a
woman she is sitting at a table her face
looks tired and
worried her hands are red and
callous she is a seamstress and she is
sewing a dress for a wealthy
lady her little boy is lying on the the
bed ill with a
fever he wants oranges but his mother
does not have money to buy oranges all
she can give him to drink is water from
the river so the little boy continues to
cry little swallow there is a ruby on my
sword please take it to his mother I am
a statue now I can't do it myself
I'm sorry I can't says the swallow I
must fly to Egypt my friends are waiting
for me they will be flying up and down
the Nile and talking to the lotus
flowers they will be sleeping in the
Tomb of the great king I must go
too little swallow says the prince
please be my messenger
just for one night the little boy is so
thirsty and his mother is so
sad but I don't even like little boys
says the swallow little boys throw
stones at me of course they never reach
me but who cares it's very
rude but the happy prince looks sad and
the swallow feels
guilty it's very cold here he says but I
will stay one night and help
you thank you little swallow says the
prince so the swallow removes the Ruby
from the prince's
sword he holds it in his beak and flies
over the roofs of the
city he flies over the cathedral with
its Angels made of white
marble he flies over the river River and
sees the lanterns hanging from the M of
the boats he flies over the market and
hears the sell shout oranges come and
get your beautiful
oranges he flies over the palace and
hears the sound of music and
dancing a young girl and her boyfriend
come out onto the balcony of the
palace the stars are so Beau beautiful
says the
boyfriend and so are
you I hope my dress will be ready in
time for the ball says the girl my
seamstress is so
slow finally the swallow arrives at the
woman's house he looks through the
window the little boy is tossing
feverishly in his bed the mother is so
tired that she has fallen asleep at her
sewing
table the swallow hops
inside he gently puts the Ruby down on
the table then he flutters around the
little boy's bed gently Fanning him with
his
wings huh I don't feel so hot anymore
says the little boy I think I'm getting
better the swallow goes back to see the
happy prince
he tells the prince what he
did it's strange says the swallow the
weather is really cold but I feel quite
warm
now that's because you have done
something good says the
prince the little swallow begins to
think then he falls asleep thinking
always makes him
sleepy in the morning the swallow takes
a a bath in the
river tonight I'm going to Egypt he
says he is very happy he spends the day
visiting the tourist attractions of the
city wherever he goes The Sparrows chirp
and ask each other who is this
distinguished
stranger it can't be a swallow here in
Winter the swallow likes to be the
center of attention he enjoys himself
immensely as The Moon Rises the swallow
flies back to the happy
prince can I bring you back something
from Egypt he asks I'm just about to
leave little swallow says the prince
please stay with me one more night my
friends will be waiting for me in Egypt
replies the swallow tomorrow they will
go further up the river there will be
hippos in The Tall Grass at noon the
yellow Lions will come down to drink on
the shore their eyes are green like
emeralds I absolutely must see this
little swallow says the
prince on the other side of town I see a
young
man he lives in a cramped drafty
attic he is sitting at a desk covered
with
papers he's trying to write a play but
his hands are too cold to hold a
pen he has no money to buy firewood or
food all right I will stay with you one
more night says the swallow do you have
another
Ruby alas no says the prince but I have
my
eyes these are sapphires from India
please take one of my eyes to the young
man he can use it to buy food as well as
wood he can then finish writing his
play oh no no way says the swallow I
can't take one of your
eyes little swallow says the prince
please do as I ask
so the swallow takes the prince's eye
and flies to the young man's
attic it's easy to get in there's a hole
in the
roof the young man is resting his head
in his hands he doesn't hear the
rustling of wings as the swallow places
the sapphire in front of
him when the young man looks up he finds
the beautiful Sapphire just lying there
on his desk
a donation he cries someone likes my
work now I can finish my
play the next day the swallow flies to
the
harbor he lands on the M of a large
ship he watches the sailors taking the
cargo out of the holds of the ship he ho
he
ho I I'm going to Egypt he declares but
no one hears
him when the Moon Rises he flies to the
happy
prince I've come to Say Goodbye Says the
swallow little swallow says the prince
please stay with me one more night it's
winter now replies the swallow soon it
will snap
no but in Egypt the sun will be shining
I will see green palm trees I will see
crocodiles lying in the mud my friends
will be building their
nests dear Prince I must go but I will
never forget you and next spring I will
bring you two beautiful jewels to
replace the ones you have given away the
Ruby will be as red as a rose and a
sapphire will be as blue as the
sea in the Square just below us says the
prince there is a little girl selling
flowers she has dropped a lot of them on
the ground and now they're ruined her
family will starve if she doesn't bring
some money home she's crying she has no
shoes or socks she has no winter jacket
and no warm
hat please take my other eye and give it
to
her the swallow sigh I can stay another
night he says but I can't take your eye
you will be
blind little swallow says the prince
please do as I
ask so the swallow removes the prince
his other eye he flies down to the
square he swoops past the little girl
and drops the jewel into her
hand oh so pretty exclaims the little
girl she runs home
laughing the swallow returns to the
prince now you are blind he
says so I am going to stay with you
no little swallow says the poor Prince
you have to go to
Egypt nope I will stay with you forever
says the swallow and he falls asleep at
the prince's
feet the next day the swallow sits on
shoulder he tells stories to the prince
because the prince cannot see
he talks about Egypt the desert the
camels the Sphinx the pyramids and the
huge snakes in the palm trees dear
little swallow says the prince you speak
of such extraordinary things but do you
know what is even more extraordinary to
me the suffering of people there is no
mystery greater than misery
fly over my city little swallow and tell
me what you see so the swallow flies
over the
city he sees rich people living
comfortably in their beautiful homes
while Beggars sit at their
doorsteps he sees hungry children
sitting in the dark
streets he sees two little boys huddled
together under a bridge trying to get
warm you can't sleep here says a
policeman go on get and the boys Scamper
off into the rain the swallow returns to
the prince and tells him what he has
seen hm I am covered in Gold says the
prince peel it off and give it to the
poor piece by piece the swallow removes
the thin layer of gold from the
prince soon the happy Prince appears
dull and
gray piece by piece the swallow gives
the gold to the
poor the children's faces grow Rosy they
laugh and play in the street we have
bread now my
favorite then the snow
comes and then the
frost the streets turn white long
icicles hang from the eaves of the
houses
everyone wears winter jackets and the
children skate on the
ice the poor little swallow gets colder
and
colder but he does not leave the
prince he eats the crumbs from in front
of the baker's
door he tries to warm himself by
flapping his
wings then
finally he knows he is going to
die he lands on the prince's shoulder
one last
time goodbye dear Prince he
whispers I'm glad you're finally going
to Egypt little swallow says the prince
you have stayed here far too
long I'm not going to
Egypt says the
swallow I am going to the house of
death death is the brother of sleep is
he
not he kisses the happy prince and falls
down dead at his
feet at that moment a strange sound
comes from inside the Statue crack the
princes LED hard breaks
into the next morning the mayor of the
city walks past the statue with his City
councilors oh my the happy prince does
not look great he says not great at all
I've seen him look better the counselors
say they always agree with the
mayor where is his Ruby continues the
May where are his eyes and he is not
golden
anymore oh dear well he he doesn't look
like a a happy
prince why he looks no better than a
beggar no better than a beggar where's
his eyes gone and what the oh my my word
Goodness Me says the mayor there is a
dead bird at his
feet we need to pass a new law birds are
not permitted to die on statues someone
note that down and someone notes it
[Music]
down they pull down the statue of the
happy prince if it is not beautiful then
it is not useful says an article in the
news
paper they melt the statue in a furnace
but the heart of lead won't
melt this is so weird says one of The
Foundry workers what should we do with
this me just throw it away says another
and don't tell the
boss so they throw the prince's heart on
a pile of trash right next to the dead
swallow
bring me the two most precious things in
the city says God to one of the
Angels the angel fetches the heart of
lead and the dead
bird ah you have chosen well says God
this little bird will sing in The
Gardens of
paradise and in my city of gold the
prince will be happy once
more
[Music]
you